I had this negative comment and it's
like there's 100 positive comments but
the one negative comment I'm going to
fixate on that and then learning
strategies to kind of cope with that
over time and again you know if I'd make
you at that point and you said this is
what I've got and I've got imposter
syndrome and I say well the first thing
is see it as a very positive thing it's
very positive imposter syndrome it's not
negative um if you see what the brain's
doing all it's saying is can you check
for me so I said this is this is the
chimp at its best to me so if you get
impostor syndrome the chimp brain is
sending you a message to say look my job
isn't to find Solutions that's your job
right as the human you find me the
solution yeah I'll give you the the
warning I'm doing my job are you an
imposter so your job is to say thanks
for the warning let's have a look at
what I'm trying to do and now depending
on the person you might want to look at
things like am I articulate am I doing
the job well do I get out of my guests
on the podcast do I get the information
the public one you could go down that
route or you could say I'm not going to
go down that route because I don't know
what the public will say and let's be
honest that the most vocal people are
the negative ones so you will get a
distorted um statistic you might go down
a different route and say let me look at
my values am I doing what I think is
genuine and if I reach 10 people doing
this is that more important to me than
reaching a million who actually don't
move anywhere so again I would work with
you to say let's look at the impostor
syndrome let's pick it up as a positive
let's give it an answer let's give it a
solution and then let's work with it so
then it becomes a positive productive
thing not a
negative I was interviewing a clinical
psychologist yesterday um and we were
talking about the idea of uh holding
thoughts at arms length and like not
like overidentifying with them so I'm an
imposter I guess if we over identify
with it and we view it as like the truth
becomes quite hard to to act but if we
be like okay thank you thank you for the
warning I'll take that into account
treat it with with lightess then we can
I guess take into account the
information from the chimp appreciate
and thank the chimp yeah but choose to
act the difference is it's the same it's
just different models but uh what I'm
saying is if I look at the NEOS signs
the orbit of frontal area is is trying
to give you information but in an
emotional way because the only way it
can communicate is to disturb you that's
its job is to disturb you and that gets
your attention so if you listen and use
it correctly then it stops disturbing
you if you don't come up with something
good enough then it disturbs you again
and say have another goal and it keeps
doing this until you come up with an
answer which satisfies it so it's
getting back to homeostasis in the brain
it's saying we're meant to be at peace
you know but you're not doing your job
it's not the brain that's doing wrong
it's the human who's not finding
Solutions uh and that's where it is hard
and sometimes as you say we're too close
to it we start listening to the chimp
and saying maybe I'm an impostor and
this is where it's great have someone
outside to be objective and say okay let
me ask you the right questions and help
you if you can't get an answer then
friends or a therapist or anybody might
come in and say well have you thought of
this and you think oh that's that's true
that's a different perspective hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye